after a week of speculation nancy pelosi
has landed in taiwan leading an american
congressional delegation to the island
sort of nation nation question mark
despite chinese warnings that doing so
would spur an international crisis and
possibly a war pelosi remained
undeterred declaring we must stand by
taiwan
okay
that would be all well and good except
the white house and the pentagon
immediately clarified that the united
states does not in fact stand by taiwan
admiral
one on
taiwan if you would and one on the
middle east very quickly
you keep telling us that u.s policy
hasn't changed and that the united
states
does not support an independent taiwan
and yet if we look at what speaker
pelosi tweeted from the ground in taiwan
her post actually states quote america
stands with taiwan
we all know that taiwan harbors
ambitions toward independence when the
speaker of the house says we stand with
taiwan america stands with taiwan how
can the chinese construe that as
anything else but that you're supporting
independence
i'll let the speaker
speak for herself
um
all i can tell you james is what i told
you yesterday uh and i'm happy to repeat
it nothing has changed about our
adherence to the one china policy
nothing has changed about
uh our stance on taiwan independence
which is that we do not support taiwan
independence
oh
i'll let the speaker speak for herself
i'll let the leader of the house of
representatives say whatever nonsense
she wants but i here at the pentagon
i hear in the permanent bureaucracy i
hear in the deep state i'm telling you
we do not support taiwan and frankly to
be fairer
i hear speaking on behalf of the biden
administration on behalf of the white
house say we do not support taiwan
americans
have differences of opinion on what
america's role should be in the world
conservatives actually have differences
of opinion on what america's role should
be in the world
reasonable people might differ over the
wisdom of pelosi's trip but regardless
of what one thinks about taiwan and
china or isolationism versus
interventionism or whatever
this is the worst of all possible
strategies
because everybody knows joe biden is not
going to defend taiwan
against chinese aggression everyone
knows it a because joe biden is weak and
projects weakness everywhere around the
world but b
because
he just told them
he said that in no uncertain terms so
now nancy pelosi has provoked china a
nuclear borderline superpower that
manufactures all of our stuff and owns a
trillion dollars of our debt
with zero potential upside i keep trying
to convince myself that i'm missing
something here what is it surely i am
missing something here surely this must
be some sort of high stakes game of good
cop bad cop right biden he's the he's
the good cop and pelosi is playing the
bad cop and they're really working china
but everywhere i look i only see
downside
nancy pelosi may or may not want to
stand with taiwan but our president the
leader of her party and of the country
does not and the pentagon does not and
all the rest of the people who matter
and who will actually make the important
decisions do not
so what are we getting here we're
getting we're getting all the
provocation without any of the payoff
teddy roosevelt told americans to speak
softly and carry a big stick
ronald reagan gave us peace through
strength
now biden and pelosi are giving us saber
rattling and certain surrender not a
great recipe for peace or prosperity i'm
michael knowles the michael knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from jacob eby who
says can we get do not squish stress
balls shaped like each of the squishy
republicans in the dw shop i would love
that so much that is such a good idea
you won't get any royalties but you will
get my gratitude whoever is listening
from the dw shop make this happen i want
a little tiny mitt romney head that i
can just go ah whenever i'm getting
really angry you know and the producers
are yelling and screaming and not doing
the job and i'm just going to squeeze
liz cheney's head i'm just going to
squeeze all the squishy republicans adam
kinzinger
that's going to be really really nice
when i want to protect not just my blood
pressure but the appliances in my home
do you know what i look toward american
home shield head on over to
ahs.com
knowles now more than ever it is very
important to keep your budget in check
you can do that with american home
shield they offer a great choice of
three plans to help cover the cost to
repair or replace parts of your major
home systems and appliances both new and
old we're talking hvac systems plumbing
kitchen appliances their plans help
protect parts of up to 23 essential home
systems and appliances electronics
coverage is available for an unlimited
number of eligible items such as smart
watches flat screen tvs and more other
options include roof leak repair and
pool and spa coverage coverage is
available no matter how old your systems
and appliances are plus they're offering
an exclusive 50 off for our listeners i
love it i absolutely you need to do the
responsible thing protect your wallet
protect your home and your appliances
keep your home up and running and your
budget on track with american home
shield right now our listeners can take
50 off their most comprehensive plans
that is at ahs.com
knowles to save 50 bucks ahs.com slash
knowles 50 bucks off any plan american
home shield be sure with the shield
service fees limitations and exclusion
supplies see plan for details
nancy pelosi nancy pelosi she is a
clever politician
she's sure even if she doesn't do good
things she doesn't she only does bad
things for our country
even if she does things that are
incomprehensible and inscrutable she's
really tough to pin down she has been
able to remain in the leadership of the
democrat party forever there are photos
of this woman from jfk's inauguration
this woman has been around a long time
and she's even been active in politics
for a very very long time and democrats
want to emulate her aoc
just appeared on
a a drag queen show to voice her support
for the drag
community
the people who change what people think
are artists and drag queens and let's
not forget who threw that first break at
stonewall
you know that is what led to us
passing the equality act and the house
in this term marriage equality it starts
with you i mean your patriots
you are
you are you are patriots and i'm so
proud of you all i'm so proud to live in
this country with you and with your
mother
and
with all of us as family
okay so aoc got the attention she was so
obviously craving by appearing on that
show i'm talking about it some people
are talking about it okay she got what
she wanted she made a bunch of extremely
stupid radical sounding statements and
now we're talking about her and she gets
another 15 minutes of the news cycle so
okay it worked it worked what'd she say
she says
don't forget it was a drag queen who
threw that first brick at stonewall is
it called stonewall yeah
stonewall which is this gay bar it was a
mafia run gay bar and then the
homosexuals and the transgenderists
and all the other people at the bar
decided to throw a riot one time when
the cops broke up this mafia run illegal
bar and she says don't forget who threw
that first brick don't forget who threw
that first punch at a cop and threw a
rock at a cop's head don't forget
how wonderful is that that's right it
was a
transvestite oh wonder they're the true
patriots right so okay fine fine it
sounds kind of radical
that's the that's the surface level
analysis of what aoc is doing here the
deeper level is what aoc is doing is not
radical at all actually she's just
mimicking what nancy pelosi did the
exact same thing nancy pelosi did just a
few months ago
please give a warm drag race welcome to
the speaker of the house
nancy pelosi
[Music]
welcome back
my honor to be here
to say to all of you how proud we all
are of you
thank you for the joy and beauty you
bring to the world ah your freedom of
expression of yourselves in drag is what
america is all about i say that all the
time to my friends in drag
it's the same thing it's aoc just saw
nancy pelosi on the same show and she
thought ah damn i'm supposed to be the
radical one i should get the attention
and then she goes on the same show and
says virtually the exact same things and
it's so clear we talk about aoc is the
crazy radical she's transforming the
party ilhan omar oh my gosh we've never
seen anything like this what are you
talking about you people are nothing
compared to nancy pelosi nancy pelosi
has been leading this kind of radicalism
for a long long time and the problems
that we see in the democratic party have
been going on a long
long time i know a lot of people are
just waking up to it now they're saying
oh my gosh the democrats are trying to
trans our kids oh my gosh what the heck
where did these woke people come from
they have been
gradually
determinedly doing this
for more than half a century now where
have you been
probably where a lot of people have been
is calling the conservatives who have
accurately warned about this every step
of the way who have accurately warned
about the slippery slope probably a lot
of the people waking up now have been
making fun of those conservatives oh you
crazy alarmists oh here we go again this
is the slippery slope argument and if we
allow this thing next we're going to
allow i don't know pedophilia and
transiting the kids and i'll come on you
crazy nuts and the conservatives have
been righted every single step of the
way this is not new aoc is nothing aoc
is a purely derivative wish.com version
of nancy pelosi
and other democrats who have been
leading this radicalism for more than
half a century at this point and the
slippery slope has
accelerated
dramatically let's just look at the last
three four years
and let's just look specifically on this
issue of drag queens
the big story starting around 2017ish
was drag queen story hour a bunch of
drag queens
a number of whom were convicted sex
offenders and child molesters show up to
the public library and read in in all
sorts of weird creepy sexual costumes
and read books for little kids what
could possibly go wrong but the defense
at the time was these drag queens aren't
teaching little kids to be drag queens
no they're just reading books in silly
costumes get over yourselves that's
that's crazy you guys are fear-mongering
when there's no reason to do that and
now the new york library is hosting an
event for
little kids little kids up to teenagers
11 to 18 year olds called learn
the art
of drag
right
again you i actually hate to say i told
you so in this case the slippery slope
we just keep on slipping until we're
going to be about seven seven circles of
hell below sodom and gomorrah now when i
want to protect my community when i want
to protect my kids when i want to
protect my whole home where do i look to
i look to ring right now head on over to
ring.com
knowles summer is very very busy people
are going all over the place a lot of
people are going on vacation i just had
my second little baby boy so i was away
from home i was in the hospital for a
few days we're going to be moving all
over the place want to make sure that my
home and my family are protected that's
why you need a ring you all know about
rings video doorbell where you can see
and speak to whoever is at your doorstep
no matter where you are in the world did
you know that ring has an alarm system
maybe you've heard about it ring alarm
it's fabulous you can keep track of your
doors your windows everything in your
physical home well did you know that
ring alarm has gone pro that's right
ring alarm pro is in the words of cnet a
giant leap for home security because it
protects not only your physical home but
your digital home too it combines a
security system with a fast eero wi-fi 6
router for home security and network
security in one device we live so much
of our lives in the virtual world make
sure you protect that as well as your
physical home this busy summer season to
protect your home you got to go pro be a
pro be like me okay get ring alarm pro
learn more at ring.com knowles that is
ring.com
knowles
an upstate new york county library has
just hosted
four events the events were for 11 to 18
year olds and the events were to quote
learn the art of drag from a local drag
queen
we went from
drag queens reading the kit reading
unrelated books non-sexual books two
little kids
to
teaching little kids how to twerk and
jiggle and strut and put put on sexual
performances in cross-sex clothing
in about four four or five years
that's how quickly that happened what is
drag drag is when you put on
a caricature a hyper-sexualized version
of women's clothing when you are a man
and you dance around in a very sexually
provocative way that's what drag is it
is intrinsically sexual and obscene
and grown pervert men are now going to
the library on a taxpayer dime to teach
eleven-year-olds how to do that
presumably for their own sexual pleasure
and gratification
and the pleasure and gratification of
the weirdo adults who attend these shows
it took like five years
forget about drag queen story hour for a
second
we went from
[Music]
pretty much no one even talking about
transgenderism in 2012 was
transgenderism an issue in 2012 i don't
really remember it being one
to
11 year olds putting on drag queens sex
sexual performance shows
in 10 years
forget about that forget about the
transvestitism at all for a second
in 2011 barack obama and hillary clinton
said marriage is a sacred union between
a man and a woman and gay marriage or
same-sex marriage is completely
unthinkable
two
transiting the kids and putting on
sexualized drag shows performed by 11
year olds within
11 years
11 years obergefell was in 2015 that was
seven years ago this happened
really really fast the slippery slope
slipped faster
even than the most alarmist
conservatives would have predicted a
decade ago
and it's not even just the kids learning
how to do the little dances for the
pervert adults in the auditorium
the kids are now learning
that they can they can make money by
putting on those shows there was a quote
family-friendly drag show in palm
springs california that taught the
little kids how to make money by
jiggling and shimmying around in
stiletto heels and provocative clothing
we've blurred the kids faces out
obviously
this uh this
video coming from libs of tick tock
there you got the little kids putting on
the drag show with some
gigantic pervert man in a thong
dancing and strutting around him
and then the adults are throwing
dollar bills at the kid
and the man is sticking his derriere out
[Applause]
who tells that a man or a woman
can't tell don't know don't really want
to know
look at all those adults clapping like
seals
[Applause]
[Music]
look at all that money you just made
good job strut around
[Applause]
oh there's a different drag queen saying
look don't don't don't forget all that
money pick up that money like a
prostitute pick it up like a stripper
off the ground that's right little tiny
child
that's right and maybe you come back up
here if you want to make a little bit
more money maybe you can jiggle for
these pervert adults a little bit more
huh
it makes it even worse the money part
makes it even worse
it's
i i'm i'm gonna be a communist by the
end by the end of this social revolution
i'm going to because
if this is capitalism if if capitalism
taken to its extreme degree is paying
little kids to put on sex shows for
perverts in palm springs then
let's knock it down workers of the world
unite soak the rich take the money let's
whatever it is
this is so
so
wrong and creepy and it's it actually is
a little bit of a capitalist problem it
actually is a little bit of a free
market problem i mean all of the people
pushing this are far left wingers and
commies and pinkos and weirdos but but
the people who let this happen often did
so in the name of free markets and the
free marketplace of ideas and capitalism
so often you heard people say listen
look we have the public library this is
a free neutral space where we can say
whatever we want we have viewpoint
neutrality and it's absolutely fine very
few people are going to show up to drag
queen story hour events but if they want
to that's totally fine listen i'm pretty
sure if companies get woke they're going
to go broke but
you know they we can never interfere in
the marketplace to say that this is not
allowed we can absolutely not no
regulation whatsoever we can't have
governments regulating drag queens and
performances oh that's big government we
got to get big government out of our
life no i
if
if
stopping little kids from putting on
sexual performances for perverts
if that is big government then call me
joseph freaking stalin man because i
want government big enough to at least
do that but of course this was always a
psyop this was always a ridiculous
uh
slogan that the conservatives adopted
within the last 10 or 20 years because
conservatives are not for small
government
conservatives are not opposed to
big government
conservatives are for
limited government
and we are against unlimited government
we're against totally arbitrary
government or against tyranny or against
the capricious use of power
but those are different things limited
does not necessarily mean small we have
a country of 330 million people and we
govern a global empire whether we want
to admit it or not you cannot have
small government in that kind of a
system it's not possible it has not
existed for well over a hundred probably
150 years
if that by the way the the founding
fathers that conservatives tend to to
like the most george washington john
adams alexander hamilton those were not
small government conservatives they
wanted a more energetic government they
just wanted it to be within certain
limits and absolutely if
protecting kids from being paid little
dollar bills by perverts to put on weird
sex shows for these adults in palm
springs if that does not fall within the
just limits of government then nothing
does then there is then there is no
government then we're living in
anarcho-tyranny which increasingly is
what our government looks like it's so
pathetic this this is an somehow an even
sadder story on the same topic
there's a girl there's a 17 year old
girl who was at cheerleader camp and she
got choked out by a 25 year old dude who
dressed up like a woman and pretended
that he was a woman and was at this
cheerleader camp why was a 25 year old
dude
forget even a transvestite 25 year old
dude why was any 25 year old
at a cheerleader camp with a 17 year old
i don't know couldn't possibly tell you
because we live in a weird culture but
the 25 year old dude who dressed up like
a chick was at this cheer camp and the
17 year old girl pointed out that he was
a dude allegedly and then the 25 year
old dude choked out this little girl
this
underage teenage girl
and now
fortunately the 25 year old dude got
booted out of the camp he never should
have been allowed in it in the first
place
but now the father of the of the girl is
speaking out
and how is he speaking out
he's he's fighting back against claims
that his daughter is transphobic i kid
you not i kid you not he says my
daughter
is 100 supportive of the trans community
i have a gay son so don't tell me i'm
effing homophobic we're not we're we're
very pro-trans we just we just don't
want the transgender 25 year old dudes
at the little girls cheer camp to choke
out all the little girls please this is
so sad this is where we're at now hey
hey hey i want to make one thing totally
clear after my daughter was my teenage
daughter was just victimized by this
hulking pervert who should be locked
away in a mental asylum i just want to
make one thing clear we're very
pro-trans
what
why
why are you pro-trans
you say you use this word transphobic
transphobia doesn't mean anything
transphobia literally would mean the
irrational fear of
transgenderism and it doesn't mean
anything because people who are critical
of transgenderism are not irrational
it's totally rational
transgenderism is irrational criticizing
transgenderism is totally rational and
it's not a fear we're just critical of
it we just say it's a mistake in
anthropology and we reject it
so inasmuch as that's what transphobia
means everyone should be very very
transphobic
everyone should be very critical of
transgenderism and reject the this
mistake in anthropology entirely and
transphobia as the libs use that term
should be encouraged it should be
normalized and it should be enshrined in
the law
and if even the conservatives or if even
the people who are victimized who are
most clearly victimized by
transgenderism are using this same kind
of language and saying no no please
don't call me anti-trans we are totally
sunk folks
you know this summer we launched daily
wire plus this is our ever expanding hub
for all things daily wire including
movies shows podcasts prageru kids
content which is coming soon and last
but not least
the formidable jordan peterson
in addition to jordan's archive of
content you can also find his brand new
podcasts and lecture series on daily
wire plus
we're even re-contextualizing some of
his works
including his genesis lecture series
which was super popular
worldwide phenomenon that offered a
compelling perspective on biblical
stories that everyone thought that they
knew well it's now available in a
readable collection with brand new
illustrations jordan peterson's lecture
series explores the psychological
significance of the biblical stories in
the book of genesis and how they affect
us to this day to watch and read the
series and to access the entire archive
of jordan peterson content head on over
to dailywireplus.com become a member
today that is dailywireplus.com
we'll be right back with a lot more
i want to get back to the international
crisis in taiwan and the economy and the
migration crisis at the border but i'm
sorry i'm getting breaking news this is
really urgent important breaking news
the singer demi lovato
has gone back from using
they pronouns to using she
pronouns demi take it away
i've actually adopted the pronouns of
she her again
so for me
i'm such a fluid person that i don't
really
i don't find that i am
i felt like
especially last year my energy was
balanced and my masculine and feminine
energy so that when i was faced with the
choice of walking into a bathroom and it
said women and men i didn't feel like
there was a bathroom for me because i
didn't feel necessarily like a woman i
didn't feel like a man
um i just felt like a human
and that's what they them is is about
for me is just about like
feeling human at your core
recently i've been feeling more feminine
so i've adopted her again but i think
what's important is like nobody's
perfect
everyone messes up pronouns at some
point
and especially when people are learning
it's just all about respect
it is not a major news story when
hollywood celebrities say really stupid
things and believe really kooky bizarre
occult
new agey nonsense
it is sad when the entire culture goes
along with it that that is really sad we
expect this of hollywood celebrities
through through whom one can blow in the
left ear and see one's breath come out
the right ear generally speaking we
expect that it's very sad when the
entire culture and the leaders of our
most powerful institutions all go along
with that as well how
how sad is it
that we are living at a time where
actress goes by she
is a news story that people are talking
about that's reported in a lot of
newspapers that's that's really really
sad
now what what demi lovato has just
demonstrated is going to happen to a lot
of people in the coming years this is
why the story i think really matters
when we're looking ahead five or ten
years
demi lovato
was swept up in this cultural craze of
transgenderism pretending that men and
women don't really exist as discrete
categories and for a while she she
changed the pronouns that she used she
changed the symbols that that that she
uses and other people used to refer to
her true self and then she realized that
was dumb and she switched back and she
admitted okay i made a mistake that was
dumb but okay call me a woman again i
know that i'm a woman again
demi lovato never chopped off her
breasts demi lovato never won underwent
some crazy surgery demi lovato never
went on
across sex hormones or taking a lot of
testosterone or anything like that demi
lovato didn't stop her puberty and
permanently destroy her biochemistry and
give herself osteoporosis at age nine
like it's happening right now to lots of
kids
a lot of kids are being swept away in
the same stupid social craze called
transgenderism that demi lovato was
swept away with and demi lovato will
face zero consequences from it it was
just a funny little pr stunt for a few
months for the kids who are looking to
her and more importantly looking to
people who have even more cultural and
political influence than her and looking
to the public health officials that are
that are pushing this on kids and
looking to the big pharma companies that
are peddling this to little kids
those kids are not going to get out so
easy those kids are going to have lots
of long-term health problems they're all
going to have intense psychological
scarring and their lives are in many
ways going to be deeply damaged if not
ruined because of this ideology so it's
funny it's cool that demi could try that
on for a little bit and hahaha okay but
now i'm she again tahihi but
what about the people
who will have to pay the price hollywood
never has to pay the price for anything
real people do have to pay the price
what's going to happen
to them speaking of hollywood
really huge news for liz cheney you know
liz cheney you know that principled
republican that pr she's a principled
true conservative
unlike all the republican party
politicians and the last republican
president and all the all the actual
right-wingers who vote for republicans
and conservative policies uh liz cheney
who is the face of the january 6th
committee liz cheney who on every
crucial matter squishes to the democrats
she just got a major endorsement from
kevin
costner that's right kevin costner took
a picture wearing a shirt saying i
support liz janey and liz posted this
with a line she says real men put
country over party
i'm not sure why this is a news story
kevin costner is a hollywood liberal i
like kevin costner's work very much he's
an excellent actor kevin costner is a
liberal
from hollywood who supported pete booty
judge in 2020 pete footage my least
favorite candidate hey guys hi there hi
i'm the reasonable one so kevin costner
supports dems and and endorses dams and
campaigns for them and now he's doing
the same thing
he's just doing what he always does he's
supporting
democrats because liz cheney is a de
facto democrat she has an r next to her
name and she'll even vote with the
republicans on issues that don't really
matter where her vote is not significant
but on crucial matters where the vote
really does matter she sides with the
democrats and she uses one of the
dumbest slogans in politics which is
country over party
squishes love this line
country over party because it makes them
feel really good about shiving all their
supporters and constituents and fellow
conservatives because they say well no
i've got to put country over party
people join political parties
at least people with integrity join
political parties because they believe
that the political party is best for the
country
they think this political party is
better than the other political party
for the country and that's why they
joined that party if you believe that
the other political party is better for
the country then you should join that
other political party unless you aspire
to be a court jester unless you aspire
to be a squish unless you aspire to be a
hack and a sellout in which case you
would join the other party but then on
the important matters side with with
your
nominal opponents
country over party
it's so
empty it's so
meaningless if if liz cheney had
integrity she would just become a
democrat officially
but she doesn't so she squishes and now
she says look wow guys here's the proof
that i'm i've got a lot of integrity
hollywood democrats support me okay wow
congratulations speaking of unlikable
female politicians there is
this story okay this is such a new
jersey
democrat story a new jersey democrat
politician was just driving through an
intersection we actually have security
camera footage of this driving through
an intersection she rams into a
bicyclist
doesn't so much as slow down and it's
not like she didn't know what she did
she slams into this bicyclist thankfully
i think the bicyclist is okay he's an
uber eats driver so he's just out there
trying to do his job delivering some
sandwiches
to to make a couple of bucks this
democrat politician rams him doesn't
slow down doesn't stop then waits six
hours to report it
and then
when it's reported says she's not going
to resign this is jersey city councilman
amy degese
and the reason the story matters is not
just because it's kind of horrifying to
look at and it's so
such a just a crazy story in and of
itself
the reason the story matters is because
it's just a perfect encapsulation of the
democrat party right the democrats who
pretend to be the party of the working
class we're the party of the everyman
they pretend to be the party of
environmentalism we're the party of
bicycles you should all just ride
bicycles everywhere give up your cars
and then in reality what do they do is
these democrats driving these big suvs
literally running over workers and not
even stopping ah whatever i'm late for
my yoga class
i'm like i want i want to go get a juice
before work so sorry
yeah whatever you'll be fine
it's a it's a feeling of these people
being above the law yeah i know it's
against the law to run people over and
then not even stop or report it but
whatever i'm a democrat politician i
don't answer to the law
the law answers to me and then at the
very end you see the the little cherry
on top of the democrat sunday the total
refusal to accept responsibility
well that the bicyclist shouldn't have
been driving shouldn't have been riding
there the bicyclist didn't have the
light
by the way it doesn't matter if the
bicyclist doesn't have the light doesn't
matter if the traffic light wasn't in
the bicyclist's direction doesn't matter
if a pedestrian doesn't have the light
if you were driving a car you have to
stop for the bicyclist you have to stop
for the pedestrian you don't just get to
run them over because the traffic light
changed at the right time and so you
think you have the right of way you
don't
you don't and then no responsibility
and by the way
i don't know that this woman will have
to resign
i hope that my reporting on it will will
help to spur enough outrage here that
this woman will be pressured to resign
but usually democrats get away with this
stuff scot-free
no one answers for this stuff
who answered for the russia hoax the
russia hoax democrat politicians and
deep state operatives caught in a
massive
massive operation to spy on the
republican presidential candidate and
then totally undermine his
administration based on absolutely
nothing based on fabricated evidence who
paid the price who's in jail for that
can you can you name a name i can't
actually the people the people who face
the most dire consequences from that
they just had to retire and get their
pension
that's it
i bet the democrat politicians who
played around on jeffrey epstein's
island let's take it all the way to the
extreme
all those disproportionately democrat
liberal politicians who were paling
around on creepy pedo island with
jeffrey epstein have any of them faced
any consequences no even elaine maxwell
who is the the madam is not really
facing consequences she was just
transferred to a low security prison in
florida
no consequences
none whatsoever speaking of violence and
lawlessness and consequences
there's a feel-good story of the day
coming out of norco california norco
california is in riverside county which
is east of los angeles
uh a convenience store owner was just
minding his own business work in the
convenience store and some thugs bust
into the store with a gun with a pretty
gnarly looking gun and they assume they
can just rob the store get out of there
with the money no big deal they didn't
count on the 80 year old owner of the
store
pulling a total clint eastwood a full-on
gran torino dirty harry and grabbing his
shotgun and blasting off the robber's
arm
so we've got the footage from the store
the counter cope whipped out his hidden
shotgun and
blasted the suspect in the arm as the
man took off another camera captured
this
the suspects after nearly leaving one of
their own behind sped off in a black bmw
x3
he shot my arm off he shot my arm off
which is funny because you can it looks
like he's still got his arm maybe it's
just kind of dangling in the sleeve or
something there
feel good story of the day i'm so
glad this man this 80 year old clint
eastwood did the world of public service
he didn't get off scot-free either by
the way i think he had a heart attack as
a result of this imagine you're 80 years
old guys bust in with a black rifle to
rob your store and you have the courage
and you have the quick quick thinking to
grab your gun and blast him away still
that's a traumatic experience for
anybody even if you're 30 years old
especially if you're 80. i think he's
doing okay though he did a courageous
wonderful thing a real public service
because
when criminals get away with acts of
crime
that encourages
more people to become criminals and that
encourages more criminals to commit more
crime and it just kind of blossoms from
there this was the premise of the the
broken windows policing policy in
giuliani's new york that worked like a
charm the premise was if if you see
broken windows you got to go you got to
go take care of that right away you
can't let the problem fester if you see
little acts of crime if you see vagrants
if you see you've got to stop that and
arrest the criminals and clean it up
because if you don't pretty soon you're
going to have much more severe acts of
crime and it's going to be much more
widespread and that's that's what
happens so when when criminals think
they can bust into a store and just rob
the cash register and get away with it
you're going to see a lot more
convenience store robberies when when
gran torino over there shows up and
blasts off the robber's arm that sends a
very healthy important message not just
to the robber whether he gets to keep
his arm or not but all to all of the
other ones as well it's another reminder
too
as the political order falls apart as it
is doing right now
we are seeing crime go through the roof
we are seeing our trust in our civic
institutions collapsing we can't even
speak the same language half the time
not just because the libs are flooding
the country with foreign nationals who
don't speak english but because the libs
themselves don't speak english they
can't even tell you what a man or a
woman is as you see the political order
collapsing it is very important to be
able to protect yourself you just saw it
down in uvalde the democrats are talking
about uvalde
as a way to attack the police
departments rightly so in the case of
uvalde in that that elementary school
shooting and they're saying we can't
rely on the cops to come protect us and
conservatives are out there and they're
saying you're absolutely right
you're absolutely right we can't count
on the cops that's why we have to
protect ourselves i'm so glad you're
making our point for us i'm so glad
you're making a strong argument for the
second amendment
yeah you need to you need to be able to
have a gun you need to be able to
protect yourself
you need to be able to exercise your
constitutional and civil and natural
rights for that matter
more important than ever speaking of our
civil rights
the aclu
the american civil liberties union has
just filed an amicus brief
in a racial discrimination case
in the supreme court now you would think
that the aclu the american civil
liberties union would be filing a brief
to the court against racial
discrimination but you my friend would
be wrong
the aclu just filed a brief for the
court
in support of racial discrimination
specifically in support of a
university's ability to discriminate
against people of a certain race and to
give an advantage to people of another
race
we all know this happens we all know
that universities discriminate against
white students and asian students and
they give
an unfair advantage to hispanic students
and black students in the admissions
process so there's a major case before
the supreme court the aclu and the libs
are lining up perhaps if we think about
it for two seconds they're lining up
expectedly on the side of racial
discrimination
here's the aclu's
own words
breaking we filed an amicus brief today
urging the supreme court to protect
universities ability to consider race in
college admissions ending these
considerations would ignore our
country's present-day racial inequality
and threaten diversity on campuses
everywhere so what that means that
euphemism of considerable race
means that we're defending universities
right to discriminate against asians and
whites and to
give give extra bonus points to blacks
and hispanics
everyone should oppose this
for a whole host of reasons
one because i i don't i don't think most
of us want to live in a society of a
racial caste system so that's the first
part
two it isn't particularly helpful to the
people who are getting the unfair
advantage because the reason that there
are admission standards at all in
universities is so that universities
know that the students can do the work
if the students get in when they're not
prepared to go to the university then
they're much more likely not to be able
to finish they're much more likely not
to be able to do the work they're much
more likely not to be able to achieve
they might take out a lot of student
loans that they will not be able to pay
off because they won't graduate from
that college college graduates have a
hard enough time paying off student
loans certainly people who flunk out
because they never should have gotten in
the first place are going to have a much
tougher time or the alternative is the
universities lower the standards
which has happened in a lot of
universities or the the alternative is
universities create new fake academic
departments to to take care of people
who can't meet the rigorous standards of
the real academic departments if you
can't hack it in biology or mathematics
or history or english for that matter
you can take some critical studies
department gender studies
blank
critical studies department and then
it's it's a much easier department you
can you can much more easily graduate
and then the university ceases to become
an institution for learning and pursuing
truth and becomes more of an
indoctrination factory for leftist
ideology because all of those studies
departments are just are just left-wing
indoctrination centers so that that's
not an ideal outcome either
it's in on every single level this
is it's bad for the whites it's bad for
the asians it's bad for the hispanics
it's bad for the blacks and by the way
it's it's it's bad for the black and
hispanic students who would have gotten
in on their own merit who then are
looked at as affirmative action cases
clarence thomas wrote about this in his
memoir he said
i graduated from yale law school and i
had trouble getting a job and i had
trouble getting a job because everyone
thought that i was an affirmative action
case and it was there that i felt the
sting of racial discrimination and it
was there that i that i saw how
worthless a degree would be under
affirmative action clarence thomas is
one of the the most brilliant and
important jurists in our country maybe
in our country's history certainly alive
today
and and he felt that sting because
people looked at him as an affirmative
action case rightly so understandably so
because yale had a yale law school which
is the school he went to had a policy
that gave
a preference to black students and
discriminated against whites and asians
so it's understandable but it's a bad
it's a bad
policy and certainly certainly the
opposite of what you would call civil
liberties speaking of discrimination la
county
just ended its unfair discriminatory
practice
against illegal aliens
so you would think that illegal aliens
would have no rights whatsoever in a
country because their foreign nationals
were not supposed to be there who
violated one of the most basic laws of a
country even to get into the place so
they shouldn't have any rights and they
should be deported right that's what you
would imagine in a sane country that was
the case in america for
most of our history
now however you are seeing illegal
aliens being given all sorts of
political rights but there was one
holdout even in liberal la county in
liberal california
which was that
foreign nationals illegal aliens living
in the country
could not
take government jobs in la
makes sense right for a couple of
reasons one it makes sense because they
shouldn't be receiving a taxpayer
paycheck if they are here illegally
violating the law
but two
the government workers
are the ones who are enforcing the law
in some cases the government workers are
practically speaking making laws most of
our laws are not made like schoolhouse
rock i'm a bill up on capitol hill and
the people come together and they elect
their representatives and the
representatives to liberate most laws
are just made by government apparatchiks
in some bureaucratic department
and now what the rule is
in la county is that foreign nationals
can take those jobs which means i don't
think i'm being hyperbolic here this is
essentially the suicide of
self-government in los angeles county
this is the representatives of los
angeles county saying that the citizens
no longer have
special
citizenship rights that actually foreign
nationals can enjoy those rights and
privileges that citizens have and can
actually make and enforce the rules
on
tax paying law-abiding citizens
this is how self-government dies
this is how self-government always die
almost always does it's usually not
because of a foreign force just totally
conquering a people
it's usually through suicide and it's
usually through corruption and it's
usually through an atrophying of
republican lowercase r civic virtue and
that has certainly happened it's really
noticeable in places like los angeles
but it's happened throughout the country
and that that is how
representative government
self-government in america will die it
will not be
because china invades it will not be
because russia invades it will be
because we give it up it will be
be because
we
suicide
our own self-government
speaking of foreign affairs before we go
john kirby the pentagon spokesman was
just asked
uh by i i actually don't know one of the
few journalists i guess with integrity
in that briefing who
who pointed out that now
the taliban is running amok in
afghanistan ever since we pulled out and
they're doing all sorts of business with
all sorts of terrorists and they said
hey hold on a second
i thought we weren't going to give the
country over to terrorists here's what
john kirby says
we know that the taliban was harboring
the world's most wanted terrorists
you guys gave a whole country to a bunch
of people that are on the fbi most
wanted list what did you think was going
to happen i would take issue with the
premise that we gave a whole country to
terrorist groups
you take an issue with the premise okay
but
that's a you problem because the premise
is real and of course the journalist was
peter ducey the one journalist who asks
tough questions in these briefings
ducey comes out he says look we just
killed a top al-qaeda guy the top
al-qaeda guy was was being harbored by
the taliban you gave the country of
afghanistan to the taliban
just a year ago in this disastrous
surrender
in that 20-year long war
you gave it to the taliban who were
harboring the terrorists in the first
place in 9 11 which made us go into
afghanistan what the hell did you think
was going to happen fool me once for me
twice and he says i reject your premise
that we did that it would be like
looking at john kirby who's wearing a
blue suit and saying hey john kirby why
are you wearing a blue suit today says i
reject your promise
you can reject the premise but by
rejecting the premise you are simply
denying reality
which is what the democrats are doing
and when you get to the point of an
outright denial of reality then politics
really starts to break down you can't
even communicate with one another you
don't have a shared experience of
reality and it means that things are
going to get a lot dicier i'm michael
nolan's the michael knowles show see you
tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
bourie supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadovsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by cherokee heart
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2022.
john bickley here daily wire editor in
chief wake up every morning with our
show morning wire where we bring you all
the news that you need to know in 15
minutes or less
join me and my co-host georgia howe for
daily coverage of all the biggest
stories on morning wire